what's a lie you recently told I wanted
to play this game yeah well it's a
little too late to turn back now Harry
and lucky for us Ellen got the singer to
answer all our burning questions like
this
first things first boxers or briefs what
shape is a brief a brief isn't like the
swimming show yeah breathe breathe Ellen
underwear do I hit this uh-huh yep it
all went down on The Ellen DeGeneres
Show Friday where the former boy bander
got candid in a series of rapid-fire
questions how are you when you and your
first kiss like kiss kiss yeah 12 Thanks
okay what are your three favorite body
parts on a woman eyes smile character
thank you thank you okay snaps for that
well-crafted answer I love it
but the juicy answers didn't stop there
yeah like not even close
who was your first celebrity crush Oh
Jennifer Aniston yep
Jennifer freaking Aniston and if you
were wondering if Harry's single he
answered that too
are you dating anyone no then there was
this yes yeah moving along
Harry revealed that if he weren't a
singer he'd be a florist and he admitted
that he even forgets his own lyrics on
stage sometimes but the moment that's
giving me life well just take a listen
what's your guilty pleasure walking out
one direction yeah you heard that right
he hits the gym to a little one D just
like the rest of us Harry has been busy
promoting his new album fine line
[Music]
and he'll be hitting the road on tour
later this year
in the meantime Harry is finding a
little time for rest and relaxation he
was recently spotted vacationing with
Adele in Anguilla yeah you heard me
Adele amazing the singer was snapped on
the beach rocking a navy dress a redneck
scarf and gold jewelry neither of them
have posted anything about the getaway
but naturally fans are hoping for a
collab now that would be the stuff that
dreams are made of but until then I'll
leave you with this
what would your signature fragrance be
called boxers or briefs of course you
can count on et to bring you all the
latest on Harry so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Holly Stephens bye for now
[Music]